collecting data and tracking metrics can
be tricky so here are some tips and
awesome tools for how to go about that
process first is Google Analytics it's
great for getting stats on traffic you
can see demographics user devices and
browser types and versions it's a bit
more exploratory in nature but you can
quickly get data on pageviews and
click-through rates you do want to be
careful because oftentimes the data does
not show unique users analytics can be
messy so it's good to reproduce the
numbers and two tools Mixpanel is
another great tool to measure user
activities it's particularly great for a
measuring drop-off in a funnel you can
build customer funnels to determine if
students drop off at step 1 step 2 or
step 3 of any process or sequence of
behaviors it's also useful for measuring
retention now you will need to be
deliberate about instrument events that
you want to track when using the tool
this forces you to get clear about what
you want to know about your users if you
come across big differences when using
two tools like Google Analytics and
Mixpanel you'll want to dig deeper to
determine which value is more reliable
and what might be driving this
difference if you're building an app
AdMob is another excellent tool to add
to your arsenal it offers many features
such as flows through the application
user exit points and ways to
automatically maximize ad revenue if
you're looking to conduct surveys you
might use tools such as Qualtrics
they're a popular solution for NPS you
might also try Survey Monkey or Google
Forms once you have a user base and feel
like you have a core product you can
optimize around smaller changes in your
website such as layout headlines button
colors and images this is called a AV
testing and Optimizely is a one tool
that lets you do this easily now a B
testing isn't the best way to go and
certainly not when you're first starting
out up next Pete from Optimizely
will discuss why this is in more detail